brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment welcome Greg Johnson to
this set developer creator of toejam &
Earl Greg thank you for joining us
alright
hello B here Justin hey Walt hanging out
to chat about toejam and Earl back in
the groove but this is the game you guys
currently have a Kickstarter trying to
bring TG TJ and e back that's right
Ferrel we're trying what you're trying
you got left you're about $20,000 short
and mutton so is this a new game it's
good for people that maybe haven't heard
of Tojo mineral is or this version of
the game you're doing this is a
completely new adventure are you
remaking the old game what is this it is
a new game but it's very strongly based
on the original game game one pulling in
elements from game 2 and game 3 the
whole idea behind it is sort of
nostalgia blast for for all the TJ any
fans that have been asking for it for so
many years yes so that nostalgia let's
just do a quick little development
history here so general came out in 1991
the Sega Genesis I it you know that it
sort of attained this cult status it
wasn't like the number one selling game
for months and months on end but it had
this real big momentum and sort of
really caught hold with folks yeah it
actually didn't do very well at first
yeah it was a very slow growth in fact
Sega was looking at it initially and
thought it might be a failure mm-hmm
which is why you probably heard the
story right why they asked us to kind of
shift gears after maybe three months or
so and why we ended up going at
right-angles and doing a side-scrolling
platformer instead sure so for the first
game it was sort of you know you're
exploring this this these big layered
worlds cooperatively but then the second
game you guys were working on a sequel
and then the publisher called you up and
said actually what like side-scrolling
platformers are really hot right now can
you please make that happen
that's right well that's kind of pretty
much what's the mainstay of the games
they did in those days
you probably remember right that's that
was the the thing they knew how to sell
and they figured that it wasn't doing
well because it wasn't that and they
said can you can you give us a game with
bigger characters and more action and I
thought and still make it poach a
mineral okay I guess try try and then
the same thing happened you guys a
decade later working on toe general 3
for the Xbox it was again harking back
to the original format but at that point
it wasn't 2d platformers that were the
hot business it was 3d yeah that's right
that was right around year 2000 when we
started in on that and that's when 3d
right with all blocky and clunky and the
Xbox head was just coming out and
Dreamcast of course is what we started
making it on and it was 3d was just
starting to look good and so that's what
we went for
and and we we did start out to make a
remake of game 1 that was the plan and
you know stacked levels and all of the
same stuff that was in game one and then
we got about what 3/4 of the way through
we're making orders yeah we were mostly
done right we even had it on the
Dreamcast so you could play online
multiplayer and we had all kinds of
great stuff in there the Dreamcast was a
great machine to I really loved that
version of the game but yeah then Sega
got kind of nervous and was started
getting worried that it wouldn't appeal
to new people and that it was too
old-school so they asked us to get rid
of the stack levels which is kind of why
you know it's random right so you you
you you replay the game each time you
play it's different the layouts are all
different and you die right that was
another old-school thing they asked us
to change was like the permadeath thing
where you die and then you start the
game over again they said no no people
don't do that anymore
perma death is not going to be popular
again for another 7 to 9 yeah yeah so
they said we want bosses we want
collectables and we want mini games and
cinematic sequences and gates and keys
slashing back to like every banjo
kazooie clone to ever yes that whole
operation yeah well it was an era
do you feel justified I mean especially
now seeing so many not necessarily
remakes but games that borrow from the
the sensibilities of older games like
things that come to mind a medial or
like shovel Knight but taking those old
platformer games axiom verge which is
Super Metroid do you feel justified that
like this is actually the kind of thing
that people want well um encouraged my
favorite Lord has I you know I don't
blame Sega for their decision at the
time I in fact we went along with it
thinking well ok you guys know better
than we do and we want to make a game
that's successful and if you really
think that's what this needs to be and
it's your money on the line ok right it
was it was hard you know but but now
yeah it is nice to see all that old
stuff kind of coming back again all
those mechanics and I'm feeling like oh
alright well maybe maybe we can really
go back old-school
and but I still wasn't sure you know I
shopped this around to publishers over
the years and you know and Mark for
saying or to you know he was the
original creator with me but he kind of
got out of the game business maybe seven
or eight years ago okay but yeah they
they they didn't bite and said now the
property's too old we don't think
there's enough of a demand so I I've
been getting emails so constantly and
then you guys are probably very aware of
the whole retro movement right and all
of this nostalgia that's just been
growing and growing over the last four
or five years so I've been getting this
increasing demand and now with
Kickstarter I thought well let's see
this will be a chance to really test the
waters and see if that old-school stuff
is still still what people want and
we've seen some success with things like
wasteland just I mean feeding off of
people's nostalgia for those games that
I mean aren't changed at all this is the
same formula at the same kind of art
style that these are things that at
least a group of people want but
publishers aren't as willing to put
money behind it even though there is a
demand yeah right it is
it's understandably risky I guess but
that
it's a wonderful thing about going India
and and things like Kickstarter or
IndieGoGo so we can just give it a shot
and see what happens and you even get to
test the waters before you spend all
that money and build the game so alright
so Kickstarter is winding down
you've been at it about a month with
toejam and Earl back in the groove yes I
just a few days away from wrapping up
what has been your what sort of been an
early or I guess later take away from
running a Kickstarter campaign for you
know trying to for trying to bring us
back oh my gosh I mean I'm sure we could
do an entire other interview on there
like give me one or two like top level
like it would you do it would you go
back to Kickstarter yeah you know it's
funny
um this is I don't know how
inappropriate this metaphor may or may
not be but it's kind of like having a
baby you know it's sort of like you
don't ask a woman if she'll have another
baby right before the baby's born you
gotta wait a month or two because it's
intense you know I have a lot of friends
in the industry you know and I'm lucky
that way because I've been around a long
time tim schafer is one person who's
clearly you know been around the block
as far as Kickstarter goes and so I've
been getting a lot of advice and I was
warned but um
man I I kind of should lie down on this
couch because I think I might start a
support group for people that do
Kickstarter's so it's an all right I had
one quick question
yeah Oh a lot of developers especially
indie guys now they get to design their
games to be you know purposefully retro
but when I look at toejam and Earl like
I I don't think anything screams 90s
more than the design of those characters
here did you give any thought to like
revamping it or two maybe maybe changing
it to make it more 2000s 2015 no I'm
glad you said that actually because
that's the whole point
yeah and it is I really wanted it maybe
we even went too far that's possible I
don't know but I I looked for an artist
this guy Nathan shorts that does his
whole thing is sort of retro comics and
and it's all about you know I grew up a
child of the 70s funk something like
that you know I was in my high school we
you know people were carrying those boom
boxes around their shoulder playing
lowrider and stuff and and yeah I just
thought it would be really fun for
people so we went for the you know the
2d sprites and this sort of comic book
II look I mean the 90s sort of
Schoolhouse Rock kind of look so um I
wanted to do something that was fresh I
didn't want to just redo the same same
thing so and that's tricky you know when
you do a sequel because people want it
the same but they also want it different
and it's kind of this line you got a
walk so I knew stuff yeah you need a
pass but making it fresh again yeah
right Greg thank you so much for coming
on in bet toejam and Earl back in the
groove just a few days left on
Kickstarter folks check it out if you're
interested thanks for watching